and what's the rest of the title dart
living dr. Laura we a whiny society oh
sure oh my gosh and it's sad because
there is no life without crummy things
happening disappointments and and the
like it doesn't mean you have to be
unhappy and in this book I try to help
people understand that the blessings in
life we have by our friendships and the
gifts we give others and I don't mean
things that we bought and Target gifts
we give others is really ultimately what
makes us happy and sometimes just
reframing reframing for example my
favorite refrain is how many women have
called me over the years complaining I
don't know what it is about you men in
socks no clue but it's genetic that you
just leave socks everywhere and so women
call the complaining my husband leaves
socks what does he think I am a slave
I'm his maid all this negative hostile
stuff and then I got this beautiful
letter that I read on the air and
nobody's called about socks anymore
where the lady said I'm listening to
these women complaining and I used to
complain about that too
and now my husband is gone I would give
anything to wake up in the morning and
find his socks anywhere reframing is it
cultural or Americans more whiny than
others you know we didn't start out as a
whiney culture we started out as the
sort of American spirit I mean somehow I
think that if we were blazing the trail
west now we wouldn't get past New Jersey
because of hardship of this and hardship
of that and it's supposed to be easier
and I'm supposed to be happy and content
all the time and I just wonder if we
have the guts that it that it took to
make this country as great as it became
and now we look at somebody to sue I
mean you take a cup of coffee put it in
between your legs and drive it car get
coffee on you and you sue somebody else
I'd be too embarrassed to let anybody
know I doesn't mean that dumb so yeah
we've become litigious and come
cleaning and blaming and it goes from
societal where we now instead of
Americans
we've got hyphenated everything and
everybody has a little group and they're
mad at all the other ropes that filters
down into people in the family you know
I'm upset because my sister my brother
cousin has this and I don't oh my gosh
yeah we we are less creative less mature
and less happy because we whine too much
dr. Laura in your book stop whining
start living you also talked about the
fact that Americans are over medicated
when it comes to antidepressants well I
don't do specifically more in general
you cannot watch 15 minutes of
television except for c-span
without seeing a commercial for stopping
some feeling some feeling and you know
people call me and I'm sad about X and
they tell me what X is well gosh darn
it's a reasonable response to be sad
about X that's not something you cure
that's something you endure you don't
take a drug to stop being human and part
of the human experience is to suffer
through certain things and to be scared
about starting a new course or moving to
a new area I call that smart and
reasonable you have anticipatory anxiety
it keeps you a little perky and aware of
things we tend to just what we all want
to become Stepford people
dr. Lurie you also blog regularly and
you've blogged about your son who was in
Afghanistan how long was he there
15 months it was supposed to be 12 and
as you know they extended them so he
came back a few weeks ago and so he's
getting used to having a bathroom and
not eating crickets necessary what are
what are his views about the conflict in
Afghanistan and what are yours you know
what because I am a very public person
and I am his mother
and he is in the military I just don't
go there do you what about what about
the war in Iraq are we doing the right
thing in your view as I just said you
don't go there well then we won't push
that you do talk about on your blog
though that you were at a shopping mall
and you had some bumper strips taken off
what happened
big breath I take I'm a black belt in
martial arts if I had been there while
that was happening I think it would not
have been a pretty sight it says protect
our son and it's the yellow ribbon and
protect our god bless our troops and
somebody had ripped him off the car and
thrown them on top of the car I saw a
piece of one and I did the mother bear
thing of looking around and I didn't see
anybody but I went on the air and I
talked about it and I talked about the
cowardice and you know in this country
we were given the freedom to be able to
stand up and say what we're committed to
what our convictions are what we believe
in without going to the Tower of London
and it infuriates me that people spit on
this freedom by doing things
clandestinely we have a statement to
make make your statement in a reasonable
and rational and same way just to be
vicious and destructive is to undermine
I think a fundamental basis of our
democracy and before we go to call it's
impassioned before we go to calls we
ought to let you know what the numbers
are 2 or 2 is our area code if you would
like to talk with dr. Laura Schlessinger
who's newest book is stop whining and
start living 202 is the area code 737
triple zero 1 for those of you who live
in the eastern or central time zones 202
737 triple zero two mountain and Pacific
will begin taking those call
in just a second I want to read one
thing from your book you before you do
that can I say one more thing about the
last question I'd appreciate it just
mind go ahead my son and all the other
sons and daughters volunteered they were
not conscripted in any way they
volunteered to put their bodies and
lives between the bad guys and the rest
of us here it's one thing to have a
philosophical opinion about any
particular war or how it is being taken
care of it's another thing to disdain
the young people who put their lives on
the line that I will not tolerate
okay you can read from the book you talk
about the median on your blog you talk
about a time you were on The Today Show
and what happened but here's what you
also write you talk about that another
coffee mug saying that has motivated me
is the best revenge is living well in my
very public position and talking about
moral choices and ethical behavior
I am perpetually attacked maligned
insulted misrepresented and outright
lied about by folks who disagree with my
opinions and positions they don't debate
they attempt to assassinate I won't kid
you it is upsetting people have even
focused on hurting my son as a way to
hurt me imagine how that feels
as I get older I tend to be more open
about my inner world in my books I mean
you've mellowed I don't think I have
mellowed I just think that as you get
older I'm 61 I'm very experienced 32
years working in that arena and I'm more
confident inside my own skin and psyche
and so I've been attacked every way from
Sunday heck I'll say what I think and I
feel and I will tell what's going on
inside of me and I'm comfortable with
that and it has been very difficult to
be me but I'm very proud to be me too I
come from a heritage my aunt in northern
Italy joined the underground at 21 to
fight Mussolini and the Nazis and the
day she joined the Nazis had already
scoped out this cell and she was lined
up against a wall and shot to death I
come from that kind of stuff so whenever
I feel was here wimpy which takes
microseconds to get rid of I think about
what kind of stuff I'm from and it gets
me through well let's take some calls
from our audience first up for dr. Laura
Schlessinger Dayton Ohio
good afternoon I lived in Dayton hello
yes I'm going to see hello yeah I just
suggest are some things worth dying for
and some things that are not and I
wonder what you thought about the
cowardice of the administration also I
agree with you on the over medication I
think it's a mess I wonder if he knew
about the temperature that they measured
in the coffee that was billed on between
that woman's leg how hot it was but she
can't have any children now somehow you
get away with and I don't know what your
doctorate is then tell me what your
doctorate and it's not a PhD nor not an
MD Thank You caller first of all the
woman who did this was about 83 so
having children was not an issue that
was just silly so I don't even when
somebody calls in just few nonsense I
frankly don't give them the time of day
next call for dr. Laura homies in
Florida that's hold sound Florida thank
you first of all that's a third time
I've done that is and I correct you
first of all though thank you very much
for [ __ ] span and thank you very much
for this office opportunity to speak to
a conservative is that there's Los
Angeles Book Festival my god are there
any conservatives I'm in Los Angeles
that will be on a panel at the Los
Angeles Book Festival but okay let's
leave that aside dr. Laura you're
absolutely correct in saying that this
country are a bunch of y knees listen to
the panels that we've just listened to
listen to the audience's and the
audience participation my god all they
do is whine and keep on punching keep on
explaining yourself because when you
explain yourself
you explain America thank you very much
oh you're very kind sir thank you
anything else for him that's it
Cambridge Massachusetts you're on with
Laura Schlessinger yeah
I'm not hearing anything it's too
breaking out let's lose that call if we
could now we can hear you are you still
there yeah tell you what let's loose a
call let's lose Cambridge we could put
people on the moon we have a hard time
with this girl dr. Laura your experience
on The Today Show what happened
well I was booked to talk about
stop whining start living and I was
supposed to have three three segments I
think one being interviewed by Meredith
Vieira and a note two and then the other
was to take emails and answer emails
which protected book about a half an
hour between so the last minute to my
awareness they said would you be on this
panel and discuss the Eliot Spitzer
thing went down and I said I don't talk
about people because I don't know them
that's ridiculous I can only talk in
general terms that's fine that's fine so
they had Helen Fisher who is an
anthropologist some fellow I don't
remember who he was and myself last
mitad on a panel as a favor okay hi
Helen Fisher says men who have high
foreheads are more likely to have
affairs and I remember just sitting
there looking at her thinking oh my gosh
and then they came to me and I talked
about the joint responsibility that both
men and women have to make a marriage a
beautiful thing and that it's sad but
when some people are starved of
affection and attention and respect and
admiration that they're more vulnerable
to it coming from the outside that was
all I said
that got turned into on the Today Show
which then had a part two to the panel
and left me off it and just let the rest
of them batter me while I'm in the
greenroom it was astonishing and it
turned into I said Eliot Spitzer should
have an affair because his wife was it
nice to him went all over all the blogs
I came back from my segment and I said
you guys were not professional and you
were not fair and this was
journalistically unethical what you did
he did not represent what I said
and then I took the time to repeat it
but one thing I've noticed when you do
other than c-span is that truth is not
relevant
next call lacrosse Wisconsin okay your
story about the medication issue and
this is my first time ever calling or
his story okay I'm 50 want I've been
diagnosed by four different
psychiatrists in hospitals with severe
bipolar disorder type 2 and I've had
this I've had the condition since I was
about 14 but it was misdiagnosed as
major depression and and and and for
many years I refused to take any
psychiatric medications I was anti
psychiatric and I attempted many suicide
attempts even and like growing children
never forgiven me but even in front of
them and and I tell you it he'll not be
on any medications what a psychiatrist
convinced me that the medications
weren't gonna make me a zombie and and
and and now the medications have made a
big difference in my life and and yes I
understand what your thing about
Americans being overmedicated but we're
talking mostly about the so called
worried well people I assume but what
about people right what about people
well thank you let's get an answer
doctor well with you know it's where
there is a serious case like this woman
describes medication is a lifesaver
as she said she was repetitively
suicidal I never have said maybe I
should have added that in sorry that of
course there are situations where a
person is probably going to be frankly
suicidal if they don't get a certain
kind of medication I'm talking about
your average person thinking that every
time they're sad or anxious that they
have to be medicated I mean a while ago
everybody was on Valium and Xanax for
things that they should be able to cope
with
when did you get a black belt when I was
let's see
50 I think why well when I was a little
girl I know a lot of little girls used
to look at ballerinas and think that was
cool I used to look at Bruce Lee and
think that was cool
so I think was 45 that's right so when
my son was born I when he was about
three and a half years old I started him
in this little pre karate think Hey and
finally I started I loved it I loved it
it's great exercise great for balance
great for your confidence it improves
every I when parents have kids who are
out of control I tell them all the time
bring your kid before you start
medicating them bring them into martial
arts with a very good martial arts
instructor because the amount of
self-discipline that goes into there is
wonderful with a real authority figure
because we've lost a lot of that
authority for the parents to the
children in the homes and in the schools
so martial arts place sometimes the
child's only Avenue to getting that kind
of discipline did you send your son to
private school yes I did
why private religious school why well so
he'd learn actual subjects and not the
psychosocial agenda social
socio-political agendas that they have
in public schools and they spend much
too much time on other than the things
that help you succeed in life where were
you raised
Brooklyn when did you leave when I was
about eight why my parents moved to Long
Island next call for dr. Laura comes
from Rogue River Oregon you're on the
air hello dr. Laura hello well thank you
everywhere okay I don't know if the will
up when you hear what I have to say oh
gosh
I wouldn't do that at any rate I
understand the anger and the rage that
the individual felt who took off your
stickers and ripped them off because of
the damage that this administration
done to the country and well then tear
all of us but not about my child and not
about everybody else's children there is
no understanding about that right my
question is though that I wonder why
people what the motivation is oh you
don't believe in private property no no
no you're I think you're not here I just
want to know if you believe in price
well tearing things off people's car is
destroying somebody's private property
you wouldn't like me to come on and take
your piece and green whatever off your
house would you I don't have anything
like because I'm angry because I'm
Angles property I said I didn't justify
what he did you're not hearing me out
you're not listening okay I'm asking you
go ahead and finish what I'm asking you
is why what motivates people like you to
put a bumper sticker on telling me to
pray for our truth we're volunteers
anyway and or to support our true cause
I don't believe it
dr. Laura it's called the First
Amendment maybe next to privacy rights
he doesn't believe in the First
Amendment either speaking of the First
Amendment you write in your book open up
the newspaper turn on your computer any
day and you will find page after page
and blog after blog about death mayhem
murder betrayal vicious reputation and
personal attacks lies dirty politics
injustice Hollywood stars undermining
our government ethnic cleansing
assassinations of the innocent daily
rapes murders of mothers and children
hurricanes tornadoes earthquakes
claiming lives in an instant dictators
fomenting terror and the like it makes
one wonder what is there to be happy
about should those things not be written
about
Oh everything should be written about
I'm a first amendment kind of person
everything should be written about but I
think the blogosphere in particular is
not to inform it's more to inflame and
to denigrate I don't think there's much
ethics or journalistic ethics or decency
involved in most of what goes on in
journalism today I mean look at what
news is today when I grew up there was a
guy sitting there looking straight into
the camera telling you what was going on
try to find that other than c-span try
to find that anywhere it's all annotated
it's all what will get ratings it's all
about ratings the news departments are
run by entertainment departments
when is your radio sore it depends on
what part of the country I'm syndicated
in America and Canada and Armed Forces
Radio and
oh gosh sella cast you can actually get
it on your phone I'm stream length it's
hard to get away from me so but I do it
noon to three California time noon to
three California time and it's live in
several places because you take phone
calls it's mostly live half to the west
and then replayed do you screen the
calls that come in oh they're screened
are you you allow people who disagree
with you to come on oh it's not a debate
show so it's not nobody calls to discuss
what I what my opinion is I'm there to
be helpful so people call in with their
problems and I give my perspective or
help them reframe it or show them tell
them what I think is wrong about what
they're doing and what would be right so
they're calling for my opinion I'm not
interested in arguing my opinion if
somebody has a different opinion that's
fine but this is my show
and the format is for me to help people
with my opinion and people listen to the
show and decide that my opinion is some
value and they call me if they decide my
opinion is not a value then they don't
call me that's the way it goes so it's
not your basic talk show where we're
arguing opinions dr. Laura Schlessinger
latest book stop whining start living
South Lake Tahoe Nevada good more good
afternoon oh good day you got a quick
question for Laura just curious do you
ever wonder if some of the advice you
get people could actually or has
actually steered them in the wrong
direction
fair question I've done this program for
32 years and I have big file folders
filled with emails and letters from
people I've helped sometimes nine years
after the fact because it took them a
while to actually let things sink in and
use them and I have never gotten any
feedback that I have made anybody's life
worse I love when people say your advice
is horrible that's usually because they
haven't followed it but when people have
followed my advice I have gotten over
three decades nothing negative I mean
people can get annoyed with me but oh I
didn't give them an idea you know I
don't treat people like idiots
I assume that when I give my opinion
person on the other end has the brains
and guts to think about what I've said
and put it together with their thoughts
and maybe talking to their spiritual you
know their rabbi their minister and use
it as part of how they're going to make
decisions I don't I have never seen that
people are robots you know Cleveland
Ohio
Monni air yes sir I'm not sure what he
said I and I'm really sorry about that I
did not have some interesting viewers
Beaumont Texas dr. Laura I certainly
know long tell you tell you what a
wonderful lady I think you are he the
advice that you dispense especially to
young ladies into ladies of America hmm
should have been done by their mothers
but I do thank you for what you've done
and what I hear you do on a daily basis
and I thank you for what your son's
doing and what he's done thank you thank
you what I what I really want to tell
you is that just keep it up what what
you're trying to spread to the young
ladies of this country and also the
young man that I hear call is they are
Americans and that they are worth
something and the decisions that they
make are important in their lives yes
they are and thank you very much
why did he specify and why do you
specify young ladies or women why do you
advise to first book was attend stupid
things women do to mess up their lives
and I also had the proper care and
feeding of husbands
[Music]
it came to me very clearly how unhappy
women have become feminist movement
promised them all kinds of freedoms from
being unhappy with burdens of men and
marriage and children and power that
comes from work and certainly I think we
can see from all the polls and
conversations and things you see around
that women have not been happy because
the basic nature of a woman no matter
how smart and competent we are it's
still our basic nature to be in a
relationship with a man to enjoy our
children to have a home have our nest
and when these things are put aside is
something beneath them or an obstruction
to them you rob women of some of the
beauty of being a woman we're not just
another version of you with different
genitals we have sensitivities and
sensibilities and a heart that's
different
we're different and you're different and
I help educate women on my show about
the differences between men and women so
that they can understand each other and
appreciate each other better and make
happier homes that makes kids more
secure and that makes for a better
civilization
now there's a lesbian feminist who is a
good friend of yours and that's Amy
Bruce and Tammy's been on a book TV
several times I was on you two are
friends nobody would suspect that well I
think nobody would suspect that because
typically speaking people who are seen
as a group are not supposed to like
anybody else of another group neither
one of us is that narrow-minded we both
see each other as very decent people we
have agreements in certain areas and
disagreements in certain areas we've had
lengthy talks about everything and she's
a blast she's very intelligent
I love her she has a good heart she has
courage of her convictions that's rare
and I admire her tremendously that she
doesn't agree with me on every point is
so insignificant compared to everything
else how'd you meet well we were both
working on KFI and Los Angeles more
stimulating talk radio on Sundays
and the whole format of her show used to
be to attack whatever I said during
three hours of my stuff
we weren't friendly at that point and
you know she was very involved in
feminist politics and what-have-you and
the national organization of women for
women I call it the National
Organization if I don't know what kind
of women went after her
because you see when you belong to any
of these little agendized groups its
groupthink and if you dare to have a
thought outside of that you will be
destroyed by that group they tried to
destroy her I read this in the newspaper
and I go this is outrageous
and I called her up surprised the heck
out of her she said I was the first
person to call her up and I said Tammy
this is I won't say what I said BS and
I'm here what can I do to help and from
that time on she has helped me I have
helped her we we have been dear friends
and I'm proud to say she's my friend
that I'm happy to say she's my friend
we have about five minutes left with dr.
Laura the next call is Clinton South
Carolina dr. Laura how are you good
thank you
such a voice of clarity in such a
befuddled word in the world nowadays so
we live in the years ago inking pinions
and Europe of knights would never even
be thought were thought of it's just
magical common sense back then and now
know what it is but this world
controversial yeah yeah and I really
think after living to hop
listening to all those other panelists
and everything that I heard over the
last hour
let's tell you that I probably am one of
those accepted cases after listen to
those people who should take tied
assessments I feel that those people are
you're sad they're all from some kind of
other parts of being new points that I
can't even follow and you know what you
call everyone back
happy loser
all right thanks caller
anything for him I can understand is
that gentleman said earlier on I can
understand what he's talking about
the thing about advocacy groups is that
the requirement is that you have to be
angry or else there's no basis for the
advocacy could open and the activism you
have to be angry as that gentleman said
earlier I understand their anger you
know and that's it they're all angry I
don't know how you enjoy life or really
do constructive lovely things when
you're constantly in that state of angry
I have activism things on my website we
don't call about them in an angry way we
see an injustice we think we try to do
our best to make it right but we're not
angry at everybody for it it's a tough
way to live
have you ever thought about turning your
radio show into a TV show no why because
I like the intimacy and the immediacy of
live radio I did TV for a while
and I really didn't like it especially
when I said something I thought was
incredibly brilliant and I said let's do
it again can somebody fix her shirt oh
Lord
no last call for dr. Laura Las Vegas hi
dr. Laura hi yes what was your degree M
I have a PhD in physiology from the
medical school of Columbia University in
New York City I have a post doctoral
certification in marriage and family and
child therapy from USC and I am licensed
in the state of California as a marriage
and family and child therapist why does
that always come up why do people are
because they're trying to dismiss my
message that's the only reason it comes
up who is Sean anybody go after Dear
Abby I'm sorry but it's your where's
your dear in who is Shawn sage you know
ask me something else is Shawn the 17
year old foster care yeah did I get the
name right I hope I did I'm sorry I
didn't mean to throw you about that yeah
let's go out elsewhere okay you don't
mind final question then before we go to
the panel do you ever talk about
politics on your radio show uh not
politics per se no I mean there are
bloggers you know I'm the third most
listened to talk show host in the United
States and I'm the only one not doing
politics no matter what's going on in
the political realm people still have
their everyday anxieties and fears and
problems and losses and having to deal
with gosh this week we've dealt with a
lot of death and dying on the show so
you never know what's going to come up
so I don't take that precious time and
talk politics there there are moments I
will say to you because I like you there
a moment and your mother said you should
be nice to me but there are moments
where I want to say something but I
control my mouth believe it or not I can
control my mouth
well dr. Laura Schlessinger latest book
stop whining and start living she has
been our guest here at the Los Angeles
Festival of Books and proud to be thank
you dr. Laura thank you well we've got
about an hour hour and a half left to go
in today's live coverage of the Los
Angeles Book Festival let you know
everything that we've done today will be
rebroadcast 11:00 p.m. Eastern Time
beginning then we'll show you the whole
festival we're also live here too